[Música]
y en directo a vamos a Washington con
nuestro corresponsal Cristóbal Vázquez
para hablar sobre este principio de
acuerdo y las concesiones alcanzadas
entre el presidente Joe biden y el líder
de la cámara de representantes que viva
carti para Elevar el techo de la deuda y
así evitar caer en un posible impago
Cristóbal muy buenas noches una vez
alcanzado este principio de acuerdo qué
es lo que sigue ahora
ahora sigue un paso bastante importante
que es que en la cámara de
representantes y el senado aprueben este
acuerdo es una paso bastante difícil
teniendo en cuenta que pues ya hay
pronunciación pronunciamiento de las dos
bancadas de los extremos que no están
muy de acuerdo recordemos que el
presidente de la cámara representantes
dice que el voto en la cámara de
representantes se va a dar el miércoles
para que le dé
tiempo al senado una vez sea aprobado en
la cámara de representantes a que
apruebe también este proyecto y después
se ha pasado la casa blanca para que sea
firmado por el presidente biden
recordemos que la cámara de
representantes en este momento es de
mayoría republicana que el senado es de
mayoría demócrata Así que se han dado
bastantes negociaciones durante todo el
fin de semana y hoy que es festivo en
los Estados Unidos por
pues aún a pesar de esto las
negociaciones han seguido para
precisamente llegar a este acuerdo que
el congreso tanto cámara representantes
como senado lo aprueben antes de el
cinco de junio que es cuando la
secretaria del tesoro ha dicho que
Estados Unidos se quedaría sin recursos
para poder atender sus obligaciones
financieras Es decir para no entrar en
deporte ahora Cristóbal Qué opinan los
republicanos y también los demócratas
que se oponen a este acuerdo
Pues es que el acuerdo inicialmente
Deja quieto los gastos en programas
sociales como Medicare como el Social
Security que es los servicios de
sociales para los adultos mayores pero
lo que le preocupa a los progresistas
los demócratas más liberales en la
cámara de representantes es que se
recortó los recursos para los programas
de subsidios de alimentación Es decir
para poder entrar a recibir sus
subsidios ahora los estadounidenses para
tener que justificar mucho más sus
necesidades lo que no le gusta Entonces
por otro lado a los republicanos es que
el gasto en defensa se va a mantener
quieto este año y solo el próximo año
aumentará un 3,3%, esto es esto es por
debajo de El en el porcentaje de
inflación anual del país es decir al
final realmente va a haber un recorte en
defensa Y eso no le ha gustado a los
republicanos entonces los conservadores
republicanos y los más liberales en el
congreso demócratas están poniendo
resistencia y esto podría ser que se
demore el acuerdo sin embargo el
presidente ya ha llamado congresista por
congresista y en total la Casa Blanca ha
hecho 60 llamadas solamente hoy para
lograr ese acuerdo bipartidista y que
Estados Unidos no entre default después
del 5 de julio